[Music]
well I know not so hard
suddenly a thought I'd swing you back to
the star
suddenly we go oh and you know where
we've been
with him but we live through those
nights
someday will remember her
how to disappear
oh looking for love
[Music]
we are tied to the wind
everything just blow oh all these homes
[Music]
suddenly we go oh and you know what
we've seen
[Music]
for arrival with them but we live
through those flies
someday we'll remember
how we disappear
oh looking for love
[Music]
well I felt the softness returned to my
eyes barely arms
I felt asleep the long dream was one
and some days I reach for the things I
don't need and all the wrong places
[Music]
[Applause]
we are tied to the wind
[Music]
everything just blow oh all these homes
suddenly we go
and you know
what traveling for arrival within but we
live through those flies
someday you will be gone
[Music]
are we disappear oh
looking for love
[Music]
thank you